il est dans la position de l'outsider le
11 juin pascal thévenot arrive deuxième
dans la circonscription
le candidat à l'est républicain cible
surtout les abstentionnistes plus de 41%
des électeurs n'ont pas voté
là c'est d'aller sur le terrain mais
encore de manière encore plus présente
pour aller chercher tous les électeurs
qui sont pas allés voter
puis leur faire comprendre que ceux qui
ont sont allés voter qui ont été tentées
par
l'image du président de la république
que qu'un député c'est pas simplement un
illustrateur c'est quelqu'un qui est
très présente sur son terrain qui a
attendu aussi par ses électeurs qui en
soutien avec tous les élus locaux
et si tous les projets avancent vite
surveillée dans la circonscription c'est
parce que je suis sur le terrain
si le député sortant espère retrouver la
dynamique qui l'a envoyé à l'assemblée
nationale en 2016
plus de 20 points le séparent de son
rival jean noël barrot le candidat de la
république en marche obtient plus de 43%
lui aussi continue sa campagne
rien n'est joué encore une fois de
nombreux et électrices et électeurs ne
sont pas déplacés il faut aller à leur
rencontre les convaincre c'est important
de voter de s'exprimer lors de ces
élections législatives l'accueil est
favorable mais il ya une forte attente
qui s'adressent à nous qui s'adresse à
emmanuel macron pour apporter des
réponses concrètes aux problèmes des
français ils sont nombreux je crois que
l'attenté très forte et qu'il faudra que
les élus soient à la hauteur de cette
attente le 18 juin la deuxième
circonscription des yvelines pourraient
basculer
elle est détenue par la droite depuis
1988 et l'élection d'un élu rpr